(calm music)
- What's up, guys?
Michael here once again at
Wisecrack's super secret
offsite location to talk
about the biggest lesson
millennials have learned since
the 2008 real estate crisis:
that there's nothing more fun
than watching people buy houses on TV.
Whether it's identical
twin-led home makeovers,
identical twins who have
definitely kissed by the way,
quirky cabin renovators, or
a fixer-upper power couple
slowly building an empire,
the fact of the matter is folks under 40
are the primary consumers
of channels like HGTV
and the Magnolia Network,
and it isn't just about television.
Younger adults are gawking at dream homes
and turnkey disasters on
Instagram, TikTok, Pinterest,
and of course on websites
like StreetEasy, realtor.com,
Trulia, and perhaps the most
infamous of them all, Zillow.
- I'd never live in North
Carolina, but if I did,
I could buy a big, gross mansion.
(audience laughing)
- Zillow.
- But why are we so glued to
these visions of property?
Is it all escapist fantasy for homes
we'll never be able to afford?
Are these forays actually preparing us
for the realities of the
American real estate landscape?
Or is our obsession with real estate shows
and online listings
inadvertently helping us
to dig our own property grave?
Let's find out in this "Wisecrack
Edition: Home Ownership,
"What Went Wrong?"
Americans have coveted property
since the first Europeans
laid claim to this already inhabited land.
In fact, taking a nod from
philosopher John Locke,
the Declaration of Independence
touted every human being's
inalienable right to, "Life, liberty,
"and the pursuit of happiness."
But here's the catch.
Locke was better known for his thoughts
on the right to property
and for his complicated views
on the pursuit of happiness.
Thus, Thomas Jefferson's phrase of choice
has often been interpreted
to mean property.
And we can only assume
that the Founding Fathers
would've been huge HGTV fans,
because they like to watch brothers kiss.
The good news was there was
plenty of land in North America
for disaffected Europeans to plant flags
and finally call dibs
on their own property.
This was in stark contrast
to the situation back home.
As historian Gordon S. Wood wrote,
"Land was scarce in relation to people
"and therefore was expensive.
"Hence, unable to afford
their own land to farm,
"Europeans were compelled
to work for others,
"either by becoming
laborers for landowners
"in the countryside,
"or more often by migrating to the cities
"to engage in manufacturing
goods in factories."
Because it was easy to find people
to fill both kinds of jobs, wages sucked.
As a result, a lot of underpaid
non-property-owning European workers
put off marriage and kids.
Wow, putting off marriage and kids
because you can't make enough money?
That would never happen to anyone I know.
(melancholy music)
I wish I had kids that
would love me, but I don't.
And even though the Founding
Fathers may have hated
the oppressive system they fled,
they somewhat recreated it.
It's like how you worked your whole life
not to become your parents,
but you look in the mirror one day
and you realize you're just like them.
Under capitalism, property
ownership does equal liberty,
at least to some degree.
- We wanna live where
everyone else vacations.
- Home ownership in
America is the best way
to build generational wealth.
So if your family historically
did not have access
to property for reasons,
you have a much smaller
chance of upward mobility
than people whose families
have been able to use homes
as assets, equity, and inheritances.
Having trouble paying down a debt?
If you're a homeowner, you could refinance
or take out a second mortgage.
If you're not, you can, I don't know,
like sell bodily fluids.
According to the federal reserve,
the median net worth for
homeowners in 2019 was $255,000
compared to a paltry $6,300 for renters.
If you're a homeowner, it's also likely
that you around a lot of other homeowners.
That means you and your neighbors
are paying property taxes
into the local schools that
result in better funding
than neighborhoods with lower income
and higher proportions of renters.
So your kids not only likely benefit
from generational wealth,
but from a better education.
And what a cool system
where the quality of a child's education
is tied to property tax
rates in their neighborhood.
I see no problems with this.
And let's not forget that
property ownership was used
for deliberately exclusionary purposes,
like restricting voting rights
to minorities and women.
In fact, even white men
who didn't own property
were often disenfranchised
from the voting process
until the mid 19th century.
As Katherine Levine Einstein
and Maxwell Palmer point out,
even today, "Homeowners dominate
"contemporary local politics.
"They participate at far higher rates,
"are electorally powerful,
"and comprise virtually
all elected officials,
"even in cities with large
majorities of renters.
"Their disproportionate influence
"comes with stark consequences
"for American local governments.
"Land use and housing policies
"that favor the interest of homeowners
"have spurred high housing costs,
"sprawling and environmentally
destructive land use,
"racial and economic segregation,
"and unequal access to
high quality public goods."
At the Constitutional Convention,
the question of whether
you needed to own property
to participate politically
was hotly contested,
and folks like future
president James Madison argued
only land owners could be trusted
with our delicate Republic.
See, in Madison's mind, realistically,
most Americans would never own property.
And if all those unpropertied
people banded together
and, say, voted in unison,
well that would be bad news
bears for the upper crust.
But like, what if we did
that for real though.
Others at the Convention,
like kite enthusiast
Benjamin Franklin, disagreed,
concerned that land ownership
as a condition of electoral participation
would create a powerful aristocracy
and powerless lower class.
Besides, many in the latter
group, he pointed out,
had fought in the recent Revolution
that allowed these guys to even
be having this conversation.
Ultimately, the Constitution ended up
with little to say about property,
and decisions about whether
you needed to own property
to vote were left to individual states
who got cruelly creative.
As we moved forward, and
especially in the Jim Crow era,
local restrictions on voting
and political participation increased.
At the same time,
discriminatory housing policies
made it incredibly difficult
for pretty much anyone
who wasn't a white male
to own anything at all.
The emphasis on property ownership
as the paragon of American
virtue was intentionally designed
to benefit one class of people
to the exclusion of all others.
So in some ways, owning
your little piece of land
has always been crucial
to success in America.
At the same time, it's
remained an elusive dream
for so many.
And today that includes older millennials.
They remain deeply impacted
by the 2008 financial crisis
that saw millions of Americans lose homes
to predatory subprime lending practices.
And they saw good paying jobs
disappear almost overnight.
And, of course, they're further saddled
with an unprecedented
amount of student loan debt,
which really counts into your
white picket fence budget.
Or your food budget, rent
budget, toothpaste budget.
Just your budget as a whole
'cause you don't have any money.
And that's not great
because studies have shown
that renting is literally
bad for your health.
A 2012 study of urban
homeowners and renters reported
that homeowners perceived,
"A sense of control,
"trust in neighbors, and
residential stability"
that resulted in better
mental health outcomes
than their renting counterparts.
Unsurprisingly, the lack of stability
that has defined millennial adulthood
leads to depression, anxiety,
and a fertile landscape of
Instagram and TikTok therapy.
But then (sighs) the pandemic hit.
And while cooped up in tiny apartments,
we started gazing longingly
at the internet listings
of homes with yards,
room for an office, and enough
space to escape the scent
of our roommate's
deteriorating hygiene habits.
- And you know how I
am about my gas range.
- [Michael] But as young
people flocked to the internet
to ogle their dream homes,
one of the main purveyors
of #housegoalscontent
found itself in hot water
for deeply anti-consumer practices.
And it managed to also
royally screw itself
in an ill-conceived effort
to profit even further
off the home selling process.
That website is Zillow.
And if you're between
the ages of 25 and 40,
you've probably lost at
least one afternoon to it.
- Are you bored?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Michael] Launched in 2006,
Zillow began as a simple listings website
where users could put in specs
for homes they wanted to buy,
things like location, budget,
numbers of bedrooms and
bathrooms, et cetera.
- I go to open houses
'cause I love seeing
how other people live.
- Then they could connect with a broker
when they saw something they liked.
According to Will Parker
of the Wall Street Journal,
"It's a platform for real
estate agents to find people
"who are looking for homes
and want to buy them.
"That's the primary way
that Zillow makes money,
"and it's a good business.
"It's very high margins.
"And so it's not a very capital
"or asset intensive business."
Side note, if you wanna learn more
about how platforms function,
check out our recent video on Elon Musk.
But in 2018, the company
decided to cut out the middleman
and start buying and
selling homes directly,
a practice called instant
buying or iBuying,
because when you put
I in front of anything
it makes it fancy.
And they predicted it would
make them, in real estate terms,
a metric butt full of money.
Journalists Ryan Knutson put it this way,
"With iBuying, consumers
could skip the long hassle
"of listing a home, showing
it, waiting for offers,
"negotiating, and so on,
"and instead sell their
home almost instantly
"to a company like Zillow.
"Zillow thought this model
would be more attractive
"to buyers and sellers."
And as Parker points out, even
if the price Zillow offered
for your house was lower
than its market value,
the convenience of the transaction
and the promise that the
deal would go through quickly
was attractive enough
to lure in more sellers
and grow Zillow's inventory.
In essence, Zillow was
simply home flipping,
a practice any HGTV
viewer is familiar with.
- The asking price was 390,000,
and we wound up paying 9
billion, plus closing costs.
(audience laughing)
- Ideally, Zillow would buy homes
and then sell them for more
than they purchased them.
On top of that, iBuyers bring in money
through transaction fees, the
real cash cow in the deal.
Zillow predicted that
their iBuying scheme,
which they called Zillow Offers,
would rake in an extra 20 billion a year.
But house flipping isn't that
lucrative on a small scale.
You can't, say, buy a house for 100,000
and sell it for a million.
The margin between buying
costs and selling profits
is relatively small.
So in order to live up
to the massive promise
of a multi-billion
dollar surge in revenue,
Zillow had to go big or go home.
Or go big and get homes.
And that's exactly what they did.
Zillow snapped up 7,000 homes
at prices that baffled their competitors,
and in many cases delighted homeowners
who were putting their
houses on the market.
Zillow would sometimes
pay more than the price
at which local real estate
agents had valued the homes
in order to entice the seller
to make an easy and quick decision.
And this practice inspired
a now viral TikTok
where real estate agents
Sean Gotcher posits-
- Why would they pay
340 for this 31st home
whenever they've only
paid 300 for these others?
Well, what that just did
is create a new comp.
So when they go to sell
these other 30 homes,
that extra $40,000 that you could say
this ones sold for 340
just made them 1.2 million.
- Of course, Zillow tried to
shoot down these insinuations
in a statement to Yahoo
News, claiming that,
"We pay market value for
every home we purchase.
"When we looked at homes
that sold traditionally
"after they declined a Zillow offer,
"we learned that on average,
"those selling traditionally
sold for only 0.09% more
"than the Zillow offer."
And if we learned anything
about corporate PR,
we can always trust exactly what they say.
But quibbles over price fixing aside,
Zillow's plan had a few kinks.
Real estate isn't a Costco,
and snapping up houses in
bulk is considerably riskier
than impulse buying those five-ton cartons
of pizza-flavored Goldfish.
Although, realistically,
both are gonna leave
you with some regrets.
And in the fall of 2021, regret hit hard
when Zillow announced that it had taken
a half billion dollar
loss on Zillow Offers,
which, if you're counting,
is $20.5 billion less
than the profit they'd expected.
It's hard not to collapse
at Zillow's hubris,
but it's instructive to consider
what they're planning to do
with all those houses.
And spoiler alert,
they're not selling them
to families or newlyweds.
According to Bloomberg News,
Zillow's pitching them to
institutional investors
like private equity firms.
And this whole debacle
is really a microcosm
of a much larger problem in America.
In the aftermath of the
2008 housing crisis,
huge corporate investors
started scooping up houses
that had been dispossessed
and renting them out,
often for more than residents
would've paid otherwise.
This practice has ramped
up aggressively since
with corporations like Blackstone
pouring billions of
dollars into real estate
and yielding record profits.
For example, in Atlanta last year,
17% of single family homes were bought
by large corporate investors
according to Atlanta Studies.
See, big corporations are
often willing to take big risks
and big losses on properties,
something the average individual
or family can't afford.
At the same time, by
artificially constraining
the supply of real estate in America,
these corporations have
driven prices sky high.
As such, neighborhood dynamics are upended
as families and businesses are priced out
of their communities.
And we're not alone in this.
America's maple syrup-soaked
neighbors to the north
are experiencing something similar.
Canadian publication The
Walrus illustrated the problem
with the story of S.W. Welch,
an independent used bookstore in Montreal.
When the building housing the bookstore
was bought by a real estate firm,
68-year-old Stephen Welch was informed
that the store's rent, taxes, insurance,
and maintenance would
increase to 5,000 a month,
a staggering 150%.
Unable to afford the
surge, Welch said simply,
"I think they'd rather
the building be empty
"than have me here."
And increasingly this is true
throughout the United States as well.
For a real estate firm that
can afford to buy up properties
and lucrative locations
and leave them empty,
it's a waiting game.
As executive director of Downtown Montreal
Business Association Glen
Castanheira explained,
"Say a landlord buys a property
with a mom and pop shop
"that pays its rent on time every month,
"but it only pays $1,000.
"The landlord may think he can get 5,000
"or 10,000 per month.
"Even if the property
remains vacant for 10 months,
"it only takes one month's
rent with the new tenant
"to make back what they lost."
Some cities have created taxes
and fees to penalize firms
who leave usable property vacant
for extended periods of time.
But real estate speculation,
the act of buying up property
in anticipation of favorable
changes in the market,
has proven too profitable to be shut down,
especially by slaps on the wrist
like Oakland, California's
6,000 a year flat fee
for homes in use fewer
than 50 days a year.
And in a red hot housing market,
some 16 million homes still remain vacant
throughout the United States.
The injustice of there being
16 million vacant homes
in a country with half a
million unhoused people
is pretty staggering.
Meanwhile, since the recession,
the value of American
real estate has ballooned
at an unprecedented rate.
But remember, lots of
homeowners lost their houses
during the crisis.
So instead of these
gains going to moderate
or middle income homeowners,
it's going into the coffers
of huge corporations
and their shareholders.
And it's all fun, games,
and easy television
for our glowing surrogates
in their newly remodeled
happily ever afters.
But when you turn the TV off,
the reality is a lot darker.
One survey referenced in Fortune
showed that some 82% of millennials
have at least one significant
regret about buying a home,
including decreasing home values,
neighborhoods that turn
out to be a bad fit,
and the decidedly unglamorous
realities of fixer-uppers.
Meanwhile, foreclosures
spiked a staggering 700%
in January 2022, according
to data company Black Knight.
This picture doesn't quite square
with the cheer antics of
"Christina on the Coast."
So what about the majority of us
left window shopping on Zillow,
fantasizing about the day
we too will join the ranks of landowners?
In some ways we're cosplaying a dream
in stark contrast to reality.
Put differently, we're situating ourselves
squarely within a system
that's rendered us pretty powerless.
Iris Marion Young contends
that, "The goal of a dream house
"sets workers working and
keeps workers working,
"fearing job loss, working overtime.
"The consumer-driven
desire of civic privatism
"tends to produce political quietism."
That is to say, when we're really worried
about finding our own single family house,
we're gonna work our butts off
instead of questioning
the political system
that puts us in this position.
As sociologist David Madden
and urban planner Peter Marcuse
write in their book "In
Defense of Housing,"
"Ownership restricts household
members' opportunities
"to engage in other activities,
"as well as their desires to do so,
"especially their
willingness to participate
"in collective action that
might involve social conflict."
When we're more focused on
benefiting from a (beep) system,
we're less likely to
agitate against that system.
At the same time, the writers argue
that this individualist
thinking means that,
"If something goes wrong,
"the individual is thought to be to blame
"rather than social and
political structures."
The fact that so many
millennials can't buy a house
or can't keep up with
their mortgage payments
isn't because they're blowing
their not-keeping-up-with-inflation wages
on avocado toast.
It's because they're being
priced out by huge corporations.
Zillow's accessibility belies that reality
and keeps us dreaming,
and that's what makes it so seductive.
But what do you guys think?
Are you still gonna spend your
Friday nights on a hot date
with the Zillow listings and a
rerun of "Property Brothers"?
Or is real estate porn
actually a lot more sinister
than the other twins that do real estate
might have you think?
Let us know in the comments.
Huge things to all our patrons.
And if you haven't
checked it out in a while,
check out our Patreon page.
We have a lot of cool new stuff there.
Also, check out our new
stream Wisecrack Live
every Thursday right here.
Hit that subscribe button
like you're clicking Buy
on the Zillow listing
for the French Riviera
castle of your dreams,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching. Later.
(upbeat music)